hey guys he's Evan she's Kendra and this
is odd-man-out
6 minimum-wage workers first one Secret
Millionaire a big thank you to our
sponsor - Lee and for supporting this
episode - stick around after the episode
to learn how you can get your first
device for free and for an extra special
offer from - Lane we will see you then
Asian American bills make the highest
median income following white males oh
that's it I don't know what we brought
together 7 minimum-wage workers I am a
minimum wage worker I am a minimum wage
worker I am a minimum wage worker
I am a minimum wage worker I have a
minimum wage worker I am a minimum wage
worker I am a minimum wage worker one is
a liar if the group discovers who the
liar is they'll split a cash prize if
the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
what live in Orange County rent Asst hmm
it's hard it's hard but I'm hanging
there rich City the bad side he was just
like hesitating so much and it just
looked like he was lying I love my
parents also so zero rent and I live
downtown may focus when I get my
paycheck Pokeball and my rent I'm 23 I'm
43 and you still live with your parents
yeah because I'm twenty one thousand in
debt it's just an opportunity to try
it's hard I'm a uber driver and I have a
van and like I got the van because I
thought I'd be able to make more money
but instead I'm paying so much in gas I
wish it would I got a Prius I feel like
you're trying really hard to make it
sound like you're broke no I'm not broke
I'm twenty thousand in debt so that's
like the same thing though what do you
do for me I'm art consultant an art
consultant yeah so art work at a
different hotel that's big money no
artists and art dealers are not rich at
all unless they're like one of the top
ones how much per month would you say
you get in commissions I've only sold
two pieces my entire four years how much
did you get for them the piece I saw was
like $2,000
you said you sold two pieces and you've
been there for how long four years yeah
that's my well because we're like a
luxury it's really hard for a young
person to develop like a client list
where they can call and stuff and like
all my friends cannot you know I wish my
parents can purchase that kind of
paintings but so I'll go by like
demographically I know how things work
you know like oh I know Asian and Asian
American males make the highest median
average income following white males oh
that's a I don't know what just by what
I think I know it's hard even though
maybe statistics may say that it doesn't
really apply to a smaller group like us
do you shave your legs you don't shave
your legs so when I saw the basketball
shorts and the unshaped Lake I was like
okay that's one of the signs do you
shave your legs no okay so see that's a
sign
okay he just seemed kind of stuff so
like get him out oh that makes me sad we
think you're a millionaire Oh oh thank
you oh I'm kind of surprised that other
people didn't vote out Kevin and David
like the first round I look poor
Jesus oh how about this I feel like
everybody has this on the arcade like
what would you do if you were a
millionaire it was the first thing you
do I would well honestly like invest it
into like businesses get more money I
have a business right now an online
business but I just started it two
months ago
how's it doing so it's going like okay I
just started it two months ago and I'm a
full-time student so it's like hopefully
grow so when I'm out of college I click
you know I've want to start my own
business be what is it's just an online
boutique she was a little bit suspicious
because she does seem like a very
intelligent woman who is capable of
being a millionaire I wouldn't doubt
that you majoring in the internet or
what I'm hearing in my online classes
which is accounting where do your
parents live my parents live in Eugene
Oregon did you say you live with them
well they lived in Eugene and then they
moved to he said that he lived with his
parents here and then he was like oh my
parents are from Eugene which is an
organ so I was like ooh he messed up his
story you said where my parents from no
where do they live oh they live in LA
like West Side East Side no they live
downtown where do your parents live you
living in an apartment with your parents
I am yeah I mean you're judging me for
living with my parents for some reason I
feel like hitting her the most honest I
don't know if it's the smiles of what
but rich people to let the are twisted P
Diddy don't live rich
[Music]
sorry buddy sorry when I got voted out I
felt alright I mean it kind of sucks if
you'd get voted I was like survivor I
feel like they were like putting out my
flame and it was just like the end for
me I don't know that kind of sucked
she's an influencer where you're you're
an entrepreneur trying to a boutique you
have to be I feel cheap going about
looks in this game isn't really gonna
get you far if I'm being honest that's
not my strategy if that's how you want
to pinpoint people that's totally fine
so the clothes aren't gonna matter looks
aren't gonna matter who is the mole
I was really suspicious about Kevin you
were my next suspect all going into
really I feel like it might be a girl
that's why I raised my hand it's not
gonna be who I think it is so it might
be one of the girls like I hate to say
that but that's like kind of the way the
world is like you wouldn't suspect the
girl but I don't think that way I think
like you my mom's always been a boss
like ever since I was a little kid you
know I know what you're saying I see
women as leaders can we have 35 seconds
so what's the most explosive someone
asked you a question I can't what do you
like to do what are your hobbies
what are your how what did your parents
do yeah well my mom didn't work but my
dad worked in construction for 30 years
your dad just worked would you say
anything oh I was just like okay I have
to vote him out just to get him out of
the way because he was starting to look
suspicious to me gots on there I mean I
knew I was out I could have you know I
could have wrote down Jesus on this on
the card and nothing would change you
said you have your own business online
yeah I just started like at the end of
July I kind of wish I didn't mention my
business like I said I just started it
two months ago it's fairly brand-new of
course I'm not a millionaire because of
it so how much do you make
I mean well okay I've made so far maybe
like not even though like 700 do you
YouTube channel
I don't have a lot of subscribers on
there but you do say last time I made a
video was like 5 months how many
followers on Instagram just like about a
thousand Instagram followers equals
dollar signs
how many Anscombe followers 2,000
something are you wait how many job
because she admitted that she was an
entrepreneur I had to vote for somebody
[Music]
I'm sorry
send me the link to your clothing
probably I don't know I honestly like I
don't think you seem like you're hiding
something but I just can't tell I don't
write honestly like I'd have no
suspicions about you yeah at the
beginning like I didn't really suspect
him but if we're gonna vote someone out
right now it's like I watch hustlers the
other day and like all the men they're
spending all this casually exactly
you're trying to point fingers makes me
think that it's year I know what else
are we supposed to do like I have to
pick out someone you're trying to point
at me so am I just gonna take it they
call got kind of aggressive and anytime
somebody gets aggressive it seems like
they're lying and so at that point I'm
just like oh maybe one of them are the
wool I don't know I said we go 50/50
dude do you guys have health insurance
if they're my mama same for all of you
she was going for girl power I'm all for
it
I mean if you are a millionaire you
don't need that money no I would be so
mad if the millionaire won the money so
I'm feeling pretty confident I swear if
these lights turn it's Ari guys I mean
you got the like alligator shirt on
though I don't know I knew it was the
shoes and the organ thing I said Eugene
cuz that's where I'm actually from you
know once I started my youtube channel
and then things really started to like
kind of take off you know things change
for me monetarily but I'm still the same
dude like I still wear these shirts I
still wear these you know dirty Nike
shorts everyday like seven days a week
and I still wear flip-flops like 99% of
the time like nothing's changed besides
you know some random numbers in my bank
uh honestly I didn't think I was gonna
win I don't know why I just thought
something would happen I'm going to
match the winners the amount of winners
one and I'm gonna give it to every
single one of the losers - so you guys
all walk out of here with cash
thank you yeah thanks to Kevin we are
we're all winners today congratulations
on catching them all
yeah oh such a nice gesture at the end
give me the money it was really sweet
definitely a big thing at a dashlane for
support in this episode those of you who
don't know - Lane is awesome it securely
generates in stores all of your password
information across every device so you
never have to click the lost password
again you can start your passport info
your Wi-Fi info your banking info and
even auto close your credit cards so you
never have to go searching through your
wallet which is super great for travel
yeah and speaking of travel there's also
a VPN so you won't be tracked and you
can access content while browsing the
Internet and other countries so for all
you good humans out there make sure you
go to - Lane comm slash Jubilee to get -
Lane free on your first device and make
sure you use the code Jubilee when
you're ready to upgrade to premium and
get 10% off make sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and I'll see you next time